>> THE PEOPLE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ARE LOSING THEIR OFFICES
NOW BECAUSE OF THE TRANSITION.
>> WE GAINED IN THE SENATE.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT BRAGS THAT
HE WON NORTH DAKOTA AND INDIANA,
IS IN REAL TROUBLE.
>> WHAT WE DID WIN NORTH DAKOTA.
>> Sean: WHILE CHUCK,
NORTH DAKOTA AND INDIANA WERE
DEMOCRATIC HANDS.
DID PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES TO
FORGE AHEAD AND EARLIER TONIGHT
HE TWEETED THIS.
THANKS TO LEADER McCONNELL FOR
AGREEING TO BRING A SENATE VOTE
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE THIS WEEK.
THESE HISTORIC CHANGES WILL MAKE
COMMUNITY SAFE SAFER AND
TREMENDOUS TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
IT BRINGS HOPE TO MANY FAMILIES
DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION TO
THIS, TEXAS SENATOR  -- WE HAVE
THE NEW BEARD THING GOING ON.
I DIDN'T KNOW HE HAD THAT.
TED CRUZ IS WITH US, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
I THINK YOU HAVE HAD MORE MONEY
THROWN TO YOU IN THAT ELECTION.
>> WITH THEY SPENT OVER
$80 MILLION AGAINST US, AND THEY
INCREASE TURNOUT BY OVER 100%
BUT THANKFULLY WE TURNED TEXANS
OUT AND TURN THE REPUBLICANS OUT
AND WE ENDED UP WINNING
STATEWIDE.
>> HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO ASK
YOU.
I REMEMBER WHEN IN 2013 OR 14,
WHEN YOU DID THE FILIBUSTER AND
I WATCHED THOSE FOR A GOOD PART
OF THE NIGHT, I COULD TELL YOU
ACTUALLY WHO SUPPORTED YOU.
I WATCHED YOU AND THEN THERE
WERE PREDICTIONS THAT HE JUST
LOST AS A SENATE.
I WATCHED THE PRESIDENT TODAY
AND I'M THINKING, THIS IS WHAT
PEOPLE WANT FROM THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
TO FIGHT FOR THE PROMISES THEY
MADE, THEY WERE FIGHTING FOR
HEALTH CARE THEN AND HE'S
FIGHTING ON BORDERS NOW WHY
DON'T WE SEE MORE OF THIS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> I THINK YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE FOR A
LONG TIME BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH
WASHINGTON, FRUSTRATED THAT TOO
MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS DON'T
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THEIR
PROMISES, AND THEY WANT US TO DO
WHAT WE SAID WE WOULD DO.
I WATCH THAT WHOLE EXCHANGE WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND CHUCK SCHUMER
AND NANCY PELOSI AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT WAS TERRIFIC.
HE SAID WE WILL SECURE THE
BORDER AND BUILD THE WALL.
ONE OF THE SUREST INDICATIONS ON
HOW UNHAPPY THEY DEMOCRATS WERE
IN THAT EXCHANGE IS COME OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, NANCY PELOSI
SAID, CAN WE TURN THE TV CAMERAS
OFF?
WE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
THIS PUBLICLY.
YOU CAN TELL SHE'S SCARED AND
THE CAMERAS ARE SHOWING THAT SHE
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE FOR OPEN
BORDERS AND THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING TO DO WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT WHICH IS SECURE THE
BORDER, BUILD THE WALL AND KEEP
OUR COUNTRY SAFE.
>> Sean: I WAS DOWN WITH RICK
PERRY ON THE BORDER, AND I'VE
BEEN DOWN THE BORDER 13 TIMES.
I SAT THROUGH A SECURITY
BRIEFING, 642,000 TEXANS WERE
THE VICTIMS OF CRIME IN A SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD.
BUT HERE'S MY QUESTION.
I HAVE TO GIVE LINDSEY GRAHAM
CREDIT.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
EVERYBODY SEEMED TO FEAR A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
DON'T ESSENTIAL SERVICES
CONTINUE?
THE ELDERLY WILL GET THERE
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS, MEDICARE
CONTINUES, SO WHY THE BIG FEAR
ABOUT THE SHUTDOWN?
>> ESSENTIAL SERVICES CONTINUE
DURING ANY SHUTDOWN, AND AT THIS
POINT ABOUT 70% HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED.
NOW I PERSONALLY HOPE WE DON'T
HAVE A SHUT DOWN BUT I THE
PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT TO
SAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THE
BORDER SECURED.
THEY ARE OPPOSED TO DO BORDER
SECURITY AND I'LL TELL YOU
THAT'S A BIG REASON WHY THE
REPUBLICANS GREW THE MAJORITY OF
THE SENATE IN THE ELECTION, AND
WINNING TEXAS IS BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THE BORDER
SECURITY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
MUELLER AND WHERE WE ARE WITH
US.
FIRST OF ALL YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE DOUBLE STANDARD,
HILLARY CLINTON, THE REIGNING IN
ONE DEAL 20% OF OUR URANIUM,
NOBODY INVESTIGATES THAT.
THEY WENT BACK TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION, AND THAT'S THE BULK
OF THE INFORMATION FOR THE PHIS
APPLICATIONS.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THAT.
THE MONEY THAT PAYS FOR THE
DOSSIER WAS FUNNELED THROUGH A
LAW FIRM.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CLAIM
DONALD TRUMP HAS CAMPING
FINANCIAL ISSUES, AND AS A
LAWYER, DO YOU SEE THAT?
BECAUSE I DO NOT.
>> AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NEEDS TO INVESTIGATE SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS OF CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
THE ONE OF THE FRUSTRATING
THINGS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
AS WE HAVE NOT HAD SUFFICIENT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
I WANT A DEPARTMENT THAT IS
FAITHFUL, AND WE WILL SEE THAT
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sean: I HAD THIS WOMAN
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON.
HOW'D DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
PRISON REFORM BILL AS LONG AS
VIOLENT FELONS ARE NOT INCLUDED?
>> I THINK WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE
A MAJOR BIPARTISAN VICTORY.
I'M A LONGTIME ADVOCATE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND I
THINK REDUCING MANDATORY MINIMUM
SENTENCES FOR NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENDERS MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY YOUNG
BLACK MEN IN PRISON FOR DECADES
FOR SIMPLE POSSESSION, AND
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
MY BIG CONCERN, YOU JUST PUT
YOUR FINGER ON IT, WE SHOULD NOT
BE RELEASING VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
VIOLENT CRIMINALS ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK, I
DRAFTED AN AMENDMENT TO THIS
BILL THAT EXCLUDED VIOLENT
CRIMINALS THAT SAID WE WILL
FOCUS NONVIOLENT CRIMINALS BUT,
MURDERERS AND VIOLENT CRIMINALS
WILL STAY IN JAIL.
THEY TOOK MY AMENDMENT WORD FOR
WORD AND I'M NOW SUPPORTING, I'M
A COSPONSOR AND I URGED MITCH
McCONNELL TO TAKE IT UP AND
SCHEDULE A VOTE.
JUST TODAY HE ANNOUNCED, WE WILL
PASS THIS, WHICH WILL BE A
MAJOR, MAJOR BIPARTISAN VICTORY.
>> SENATOR, WELL SAID.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.